peu la crise de bizerte continue aux
abords de la médina qui selon certaines
rumeurs se transformerait encore tranché
les éléments tunisien reste le doigt sur
la gâchette
[Musique]
de l'autre côté de la rue les français
veulent aussi derrière leurs abris
et les chars continuent de garder les
issues pendant quelques jours le
ravitaillement a manqué boulangerie à
siéger dans la ville européenne camions
de pain à siéger dans la médina
il semble qu'aujourd'hui tout soit
rentré dans l'ordre et que le
ravitaillement se fasse à peu près
normalement
et même il y a quelques fois entre les
adversaires d'hier comme un essai de
souris c'est dans ce climat devait y
d'armes que monsieur h invité par
monsieur bourguiba est venu selon ses
propres paroles se mettre à la
disposition du gouvernement tunisien
le secrétaire général des nations unies
effectué ce voyage à titre personnel
sans avoir reçu de l'onu une quelconque
mission
[Musique]
c'est cependant sous le couvert du
pavillon onusien que monsieur h qui
d'abord ne devait pas y aller
décida soudain de se rendre à bizerte
[Musique]
et voici l'incident la voiture de
monsieur en marche elle avait franchi
sans encombre le premier barrage
français au second barrage
les parachutistes l'arrêt puis le
l'installer l'incident a duré 30
secondes mais on en parlera partout et
nous serons bien sûr que monsieur h à
rencontrer des unités françaises sur son
chemin mais nous ne savons pas si
monsieur h à jeter un regard sur les
tranchées tunisienne creuser pour
encercler la base cause première de la
crise de bizerte
[Musique]
et
du côté français l'amiral anne ont des
idées devant les cercueils des 25
soldats tombés au combat
une brève cérémonie les corps seront
demain transporté en terre française
a new york la nouvelle plaine de la
tunisie réunissait à nouveau le conseil
de sécurité cette séance devait se
dérouler sans la participation de la
france
aucune nouvelle recommandation ne devait
d'ailleurs en sortie mais la crise de
bizerte n'est pas finie et l'arrivée à
marseille d'un millier de français
fuyant bizerte et le signe concret d'une
inquiétude générale que fuient ces
pauvres gens qui n'en portent avec eux
que leur vie libre imad futur
l'arrestation possible l'internement ou
plus encore le retour du drame absurde
[Musique]
côte à côte sur les quais de toulon deux
étranges navy le premier est tout
simplement le bathyscaphe qui plongea à
4050 m le second son successeur qui se
nomme archimède aura des possibilités
infiniment plus grande puisque il
descendra ça se faire à la profondeur de
11000 mètres et que des hélices lui
permettront de se mouvoir et de se
diriger
voici donc un instrument de grande
classe pour l'exploration des gouffres
de l'océan et le commandant ho l'un de
ses promoteurs peut ambitionner d'ores
et déjà le titre d'explorateurs des
grands fonds ou stop nautique georges
vallerey championnats de france de
natation 1961 dans le 100 m nage libre
la course sera serrée entre gérard grau
pèse un nageur de 18 ans à peine et le
tenant du titre
alain got vallès finalement gros pèse à
la ligne numéro 4 l'un portera en 57
secondes 2/10 battant god vallès d'un
dixième de seconde de balès et groupe f
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
surprise dans la finale du 100 m nage
libre dames marie-laure gaillot à la
ligne numéro 4 gagnera nettement en 8
minutes 5 secondes 8/10 et battra la
championne de france et d'afrique
[Musique]
et la france est la première à féliciter
la nouvelle champions
[Applaudissements]
dans le 100 m papillon championnat la
ligne numéro 4 battra le record de
france en une minute 5 secondes
coma qui se détachera après le virage là
résisté au retour désespéré de
jean-pierre moines qui se classera
second ayant sans doute produit son
effort un peu trop tard
[Applaudissements]
sur un visage de gas le sourire du
vainqueur à yu xin gong qu'on surnomme
poétiquement la ville de l'aurore on à
célébrer joyeusement la fête de l'eau
qui est la principale solennité d'une
nouvelle
ces réjouissances se caractérise par une
aspersion mutuelle qui tient lieu de nos
formules de meilleur 2e
et les visiteurs de marque que recevait
la ville à ce moment messieurs chou en
laye premier ministre de chine et où
nous premier ministre de birmanie n'ont
pas fait de difficultés pour se joindre
aux joyeuses arroseurs et arrosé
ces petites maisons de bois sont les
habitations d'une étrange tribu de
l'inde descendants des sandales
alexandre juif rescapé de la captivité
de babylone le mystère entoure ce peuple
des taux das réduit à 500 à peine
aujourd'hui étrange personnage barbu est
doté d'un penchant pour la méditation le
travail avilissant leur étant interdit
[Musique]
quant aux femmes chacune à plusieurs
maris
vital de goli chez pierre grand bac qui
ont rapporté ces images des auteurs du
nil guiry ont assisté à la plus
singulière des cérémonies d'audace les
funérailles d'une jeune femme de 20 ans
[Musique]
la montagne les jeunes gens sont allés
capturer les buffles sauvage consacré au
dieu n 12 buffle qu'un prêtre assommera
pour que la ram qui épure se chargent
des péchés de la morte
alors commence au milieu des
gémissements des pleureuses
la deuxième partie de la cérémonie
l'incinération du cadavre
un jour viendra sans doute ou le dernier
toda disparaîtra et l'on considérera ces
images à la lumière de ce fait comme le
témoignage d'un instinct d'autant plus
précieux qu'il va périr biscarrosse le
décollage d'un dragon et 15 cents mètres
plus bas une croix au centre de deux
cercles concentriques
c'est là que les concurrents du
championnat france de parachutisme
devait poser les pieds on se dirige en
tirant sur les suspentes et c'est déjà
bien d'arriver dans le cercle
l'épreuve de précision à partir de 15
cents mètres comportait ainsi quatre
sauts il faut rappeler que seuls conte
plein droit ou les pieds ont touché le
sol
[Musique]
l'adjudant arassus qui devait confirmer
son titre de champion de france a réussi
dans cette épreuve très joli saut à 60
centimètres du sang
[Musique]
au stade de l'année car as tu gare plus
de 10000 gymnastes appartenant à 17
nations s'affrontent dans une vaste
compétition qui porte sur les exercices
les plus classiques de ce sport aux
anneaux d'abord pour un équilibre en
force
puis aux barres parallèles où les
concurrents rivalisent de légèreté comme
de puissance
et voici maintenant pour terminer un
exercice d'ensemble au tremplin dans
lequel les gymnastes semble défier les
lois de la pesanteur
et
à porto novo sa capitale actuelle comme
à cotonou sa capitale futur la jeune
république du dahomey à célébrer le
premier anniversaire de son indépendance
devant l'assemblée nationale réunie en
séance solennelle le président de la
république monsieur hubert maga a évoqué
les efforts et les résultats d'une année
d'indépendance et insisté sur les
avantages de la collaboration française
magnifique exemple at il dit est gage
d'une amitié solide qui ne se démentira
pas le lendemain à cotonou le président
maga passait en revue les unités de la
jeune armée d'annonay
[Musique]
ces unités qui comporte toutes les armes
devaient ensuite défiler devant un
public enthousiaste
ce défilé devait être complété à porto
novo par un défilé populaire qui mettait
en relief les forces vives du pays
sans oublier bien entendu ce pittoresque
traditionnelle d'un vieux peuple porté à
l'état de jeune nation
larry à vue ou quai d'orsay les
ministres des affaires étrangères des
quatre messieurs dean rusk lors du yom
fun brentano et couve de murville réunis
pour fixer la position occidentale sur
le problème de berlin toujours au
premier plan des préoccupations
les quatre ministres devaient notamment
envisager certaines mesures militaires
et économiques
berlin n'a pas fini de faire parler de
lui
et
oui
ça rase sur la côte du pays basque
espagnol sonore de compter deux
visiteurs de marque le roi baudouin et
la reine fabiola les souverains sont
venus passer la des vacances familiales
ils sont en effet les autres du beau
frère et de la soeur de la reine des
belges
oh
patrac ans actuellement pour bébé qui
est arrivé à rome pour aller poursuivre
à spolète le tournage du film de louis
malle
il va sans dire que l'apparition de la
vedette française numéro un n'est pas
passé inaperçu on assure même que les
cameramen et photographes rona en ont
gardé quelques courbatures et quelques
bleus
quant à brigitte inquiète de tant de
chaleur elle n'a songé qu'elles sont
réfugiés dans sa voiture pauvre bébé
à mayenne c'est un souvenir
particulièrement émouvant que sont venus
évoquer avec toute la ville deux
américaines madame n'a craqué mais sa
fille près du pont qui porte aujourd'hui
leur nom c'est une belle histoire
le 5 août 1944 ndiaye avait réussi tout
seul à empêcher les allemands de faire
sauter le dernier pont il permet ainsi à
l'armée patton de continuer son avance
mais il y avait laissé la vie ce jazz sa
pleine à craquer son visage les
habitants de mayenne ont pu l'oublier
ils n'oublieront ni son nom ni son
sacrifice
[Musique]
nous ne sommes plus au temps où
l'amateur de nage sous marine était un
être singulier 15,1 ont changé tout cela
et qui paie aujourd'hui de masques et de
bouteilles d'air les nageurs sous marin
est maintenant un autre banal de la
plage et s'il en est pour qui le fond de
la mer est un terrain de chasse ou de
recherche
si les pêcheurs d'un fort entre
maintenant dans la même légende que les
pêcheurs de perles tous les plongeurs
sous-marins n'appartiennent pas à cette
élite des bas fonds
il y a aussi la foule banale des deux
mètres de fond ce que nous appellerons
les sous l'eau la plage on la connaît
comme dit l'autre ce n'est plus une
plage c'est une foule une foule au ras
du sol de cet observatoire commode et
confortable on voit se diriger vers la
mer des paires de jambes de toutes les
élégances de tous les âges de toutes les
prudents et de toutes les hardiesses
[Musique]
pour y chercher sans doute un peu de
solitude
[Musique]
enfin seule la solitude la tranquillité
la paix pas si vite
le sous l'eau et la visible qui vous
dévisagent juge votre forme sportive
s'offrent avec une indiscrétion qu'on
pourrait parfois dire blâmable le
spectacle que vous donnez et mon dieu
même un homme dans l'eau peut être
ridicule attention à cet observateur
indiscrets on peut voir sous l'eau de
ces choses que vous espériez bien ne pas
voir découvert et puis dans cette crique
où vous vous sentiez au bout du monde
maintenant plus de sécurité
l'ennemi peut sournoisement s'approcher
et soudain apparaît quel problème car
avec cette prolifération des sous l'eau
n'allons nous pas voir le fond de la mer
devenir aussi peuplé que la plage
va-t-il falloir qu'ils transportaient
les règlements de la circulation et crée
encore d'agents pourri manier le bâton
blanc
[Musique]
finira tôt par jouer au naturel sur une
terrasse sous marine la fameuse partie
de cartes d'un pagnol devenue cette fois
parfaitement pleinement totalement
méditerranée
[Musique]
je
coutume d'été sur la vaste plage de
santander les courses paysanne qui s'y
déroule comme un derby rustique leurs
puissants jockey monté sur deux robustes
montures sont naturellement loin de
faire songer à longchamp west ham mais
le coeur y est
courses de chars ont aussi leur place au
cours de ce festival du percheron mais
là aussi ce sont des chevaux de tous les
jours a trait à leurs charrettes
quotidienne rien des performances
décoratives et sportif de ben-hur
et tout cela joyeux animé vivant comme
le tableau inconnu d'une chevauchée
rustique à la mode espagnole
et la victoire est comme toutes les
victoires solennellement cours année
[Applaudissements]
chaque année durant quinze jours les
lacs de la frise en landes s'offre aux
courses de voiliers mais c'est un
spectacle qui n'a qu'une parenté
lointaine avec les modernes reg ap les
bâtiments en lice les transbordeurs
qu'on utilisait autrefois dans la
province ne sont pas précisément doué
d'une exquise légèreté mais leur
évolution et gagnent en majesté
et comme l'ont fait leurs pères leurs
grands airs et leur arrière grand père
les frisons qui ont gardé intact le goût
de l'ancien navigation à voile se
livrent chaque année pour le sport et
pour le plaisir à ce tranquille
championne
les championnats d'allemagne de ski
nautique elles se sont déroulées sur la
moselle
l'élite des skieurs allemands se prépare
est ici au championnat d'europe où ils
seront des concurrents redoutables et
plus loin peut-être à la rencontre de
miami où auront lieu les championnats du
monde
la jeune et jolie championne ne valent
pas au niveau galles qui l'a emporté
dans le slalom comme dans des figures a
montré une parfaite maîtrise et sera
certainement l'une des compétitrices les
plus en vue dans le prochain tournoi
européen
il nous faut du nouveau nom futile plus
au monde s'écriait naguère un poème
l'ars a fait sien ce cri de guerre et
dans son atelier de métal au sculpteur
medcalf s'efforce de donner un sens
nouveau à la matière niki de saint
phalle elle fait de la peinture c'est à
dire qu'elle a enfoui des sachets de
couleur sous une couche de plâtre après
quoi il ne reste plus qu'à libérer la
couleur à la carabine
[Musique]
pourquoi pas il y en a bien qui peignent
au pistolet
[Musique]
et voilà
tingle y est d'une autre école celle des
mobiles mais ces mobiles à lui sont des
mobiles sonore ces méthodes unissent à
la fois la vision de l'artiste et le
manuel du petit bricoleur c'est pourquoi
on retrouve dans ses créations les
objets les plus usuelles et les plus
hétéroclites exemple
nous avons enfin le mobile musical qu'en
pensez vous
abidjan qui célébrait le premier
anniversaire de l'indépendance de la
côte d'ivoire a été pour deux jours le
lieu de rendez-vous du monde entier
nouveau pas même la présidence vaste
édifice ultramoderne bâti en huit mois
monsieur houphouët boigny a accueilli en
effet avec le frère du président kennedy
et le représentant de l'urss des
personnalités venues de tous les
continents
le président de la république de côte
d'ivoire devait présenter à ses invités
au nombre desquels se trouvaient le
président de la république sénégalaise
monsieur léopold senghor et monsieur
michel debré premier ministre français
un résumé des forces vives de la nation
à l'occasion d'un grand défilé où
devaient figurer avec la jeune armée
les organisations économiques et
sociales ivoirienne trois mille hommes
des différentes armes ont déclenché
l'enthousiasmé général
on a pu découvrir les premiers éléments
d'une marine entre anet
à leur suite les formations politiques
sportives syndicales et économiques ont
évoqué les chances d'une nation qui
n'est il y a tout juste un an
regarde résolument vers l'avenir
une nouvelle crise de berlin a déclenché
dans la zone occidentale de l'ex
capitale allemande un subite
accroissement du nombre des transfuges
qui depuis 1945 ne cesse de franchir des
stands ouest le rideau de fer
alors que le nombre de ces transfuges de
l'est flottaient autour de 4000 par
semaine il s'est soudain élevé à 15
cents et même à 2000 par jour
ces réfugiés qui ont tout quitté sont
venus les mains vides
les services d'accueil de l'ouest sont
donc dans la nécessité de pourvoir à
leurs besoins et de leur fournir les
objets de première nécessité du centre
d'hébergement ils sont ensuite dirigés
vers l'allemagne fédérale où les
services de reclassement s'occupant
d'eux hémorragie sans fin pour
l'allemagne de l'est
problème pour l'allemagne fédérale
depuis quinze ans plus de deux millions
d'allemands sont ainsi passés d'est en
ouest
et
l'arrivée d'un iliouchine 18 à
l'aérodrome devenu covo watts en tête
avec monsieur khrouchtchev la famille du
deuxième cosmonaute soviétique a manqué
pour moscou le début de la journée
titoff l'homme qui a fait dix sept fois
le tour de la terre en 25 heures a
franchi au pas de charge la distance qui
le séparait de la tribune officielle et
se devaient être geste pour gest la
répétition de la réception qui avait
connu youri gagarine
debra de monsieur coach of germann qui
peuvent passer tour à tour dans ceux de
son épouse tamara de sa soeur de sa mère
et de son thème
et enfin de youri gagarine
[Musique]
moscou allait pouvoir à son tour a clamé
son héros et lui faire le plus large
triangle
c'était jour férié dans la capitale
soviétique et 2 millions de moscovites
sont passés sur la place rouge ce jour
là sous le portrait de lénine
on appréciera sans doute pas que
monsieur coach a fait profiter de cette
journée pour évoquer la menace d'une
super d'onde capable d'anéantir le monde
mais on applaudira sans réserve au
nouveau pas qui vient d'être accompli
dans la conquête de l'espace et que
symboliste un simple de visage jeune et
souriant
[Musique]
le ministre des finances monsieur
baumgartner est allé tout spécialement à
moscou à la tête d'une importante
délégation pour inaugurer l'exposition
france ex pendant un mois les moscovites
pourront voir de près les 1000 aspects
de la france d'aujourd'hui un pays qui
n'est en dépit de certains avis ni des
cas d'un nid empêtré dans des
contradictions fatale
en l'absence de monsieur coach of madame
kucera fut la première visiteuse en
compagnie de quelques membres de sa
famille et de plusieurs personnalités
soviets
si le coeur artificiel la maquette
animée du réacteur g2 de marcoule et la
soucoupe sous-marine du commandant
cousteau sont les premiers pôles
d'intérêt de ces quarante mille mètres
carrés d'espacés couverts des
présentations de la mode française elle
déchaîne la curiosité et si cette vaste
entreprise de relations publiques est
l'objet de certaines critiques de la
presse soviétique
on ne pourra pas dire en tout cas que le
public l'a volontairement bouté à la
veille du débat devenu il n'y a pas eu
de nouvelles batailles de bizet les à
l'appel de monsieur bourguiba la tunisie
manifestent à tunis même s'est déroulée
la principale des manifestations
organisées par le gouvernement tunisien
et le néo destour pour redonner du
relief à la sphère qui s'estompe est un
peu derrière l'actualité vernis noir
une foule bardé de drapeaux et de
banderoles à défiler jusqu'à l'immeuble
du néo destour pourriat clamé le
président bourguiba
réduite au débat onusien auquel la
france ne prend aucune part
bachelot durant la capitale du gabon qui
porte un nom éloquent de libreville a
fait du premier anniversaire de son
indépendance sa première fête nationale
avec la délégation française présidée
par monsieur jacquinot près de quarante
délégations étrangères étaient venus
manifester leur sympathie aux jeunes est
à
la plus importante des cérémonies
devaient faire défiler devant monsieur
léon m'ba président de la république
gabonaise avec la jeune armée du nouvel
état souverain
les enfants des écoles et les groupes
sportifs
à la suite les chars des activités
sociales les groupes folkloriques
le tout au milieu d'un enthousiasme
sympathique qui donnait à ces festivités
l'air donne enfin d'une fête familiale
partout dans les rues des groupes animés
restituer le climat exubérant et coloré
du gabon traditionnel ce gabon qui à
travers les avatars de la vie n'a jamais
connu de différends entre africains et
européens et où le mât pas honte
d'avouer son affection pour la france
le plus épais mystère plane sur l'ancien
et belle résidence du cardinal de
vendôme à aix en provence où s'étaient
ouvertes l'exposition cézanne huit
tableaux ci sont volatilisés sans qu'on
sache ni comment ni pourquoi
comment la conservatrice qui dormaient
dans le pavillon et les agents de garde
seule demande toujours en escaladant la
façade et en atteignant une fenêtre par
la corniche peut-être deal enquête
[Musique]
pourquoi cette question ce sont les
visiteurs qui cela pose en contemplant
la place vide de la nature morte au
crâne
on s'imagine mal en effet qu'il puisse
exister une possibilité de monnayer des
toiles aussi célèbre que les joueurs de
cartes alors alors on interroge
longuement le mur ribes chaîne mont
mercure en vendée a été également le
témoin d'un vol mais le plus honnête du
monde
un hélicoptère a été un saint michel de
11 100 kg à prendre son essor vers le
clocher de l'église où on l'avait retiré
voici quelques années pour réparer des
blessures dues à une tente est trop
violent
il n'a fallu que deux jours pour mener
la faire à son terme alors que la même
opération avait nécessité quatre mois en
comme quoi l'hélicoptère fait bon ménage
avec les anges
il
berlin que partageaient une ligne
officielle mais idéal vient de voir
tomber entre ces deux zones le rideau de
fer
ce natale à berlin s'est éveillé au
bruit des marteaux-piqueurs qui trouait
l'astral
dans la nuit le gouvernement de bangkok
pour enrayer l'hémorragie des
populations vers l'allemagne de l'ouest
qui en dix ans lui avait enlevé deux
millions d'âmes avait décrété la
fermeture des communications entre les
deux zones et sur 40 km de longueur
ces 40 km par lesquels on pouvait encore
choisir la liberté la barrière
s'établissait rues barrées bombard et
métro arrêtée
il ne restait sur ses 40 km que 18
points de passage le contrôle et essais
vers l'allemagne de l'est ce cadenassait
[Applaudissements]
jamais
le maire de berlin ouest monsieur willy
bram était venu se rendre compte par
lui-même de l'herméticité du système que
seuls des harnais une vingtaine de
transfuges parvenait à traverser chaque
jour ils pouvaient voir la porte de
brandebourg symbole de la séparation des
deux berlin les chars des vopos prendre
position un authentique rideau de fer il
allait maintenant l'allemagne de l'est
les commandements alliés avaient
naturellement réagi immédiatement en
protestante auprès des autorités
soviétiques et en assurant le maire de
berlin monsieur willy brandt de leur
soutien est venu de washington le vice
président des états unis monsieur linh
dan johnson assure est à la foule
berlinoise
les etats unis connaissent leur
engagement et sont décidés à accomplir
tous leurs devoirs
il ne représentait le général de sus
clair l'homme du pont aérien des heures
troubles de 1948 qui venait de réclamer
son poste à berne en même temps renfort
symbolique sans doute mais significatif
15 cents soldats américains avec 250
véhicules avaient franchi la frontière
et ouvrant sans encombre les 150 km du
couloir routier de breivik à berlin
faisaient leur entrée aux acclamations
de la foule
les derniers groupes de réfugiés irait
grossir les rangs de ceux dont la fuite
était pour le gouvernement ou le bridge
une sorte de condamnation berlin
maintenant était coupée en deux
sans fissures il y aurait tous les jours
du côté de l'est des groupes immobile
devant les barbelés mais la police de
l'est et là elle a l'oeil sur ces groupe
d'allemands en quête d'espoir par dessus
ces barrières deux mondes se regardent
et attendent le coeur serré
championnats d'europe de ski nautique à
bagnols à saint espagne championnat de
très haute qualité vous n'avez jamais vu
mieux
les skieurs français ont été des maîtres
de cette compétition deux gagnants
individuel jean marie muller et béatrice
martelly et la victoire tariq
quand on en arrive à cette perfection ce
n'est plus du sport mais de là
reutlingen à lors des championnats
d'allemagne de plomb' planète de quoi
vous couper le souffle et la parole de
surcroît ce merveilleux petit balai nous
le devons à la fantaisie de l'opérateur
de 100 langues parlées la caméra
un plongeon de haut-vol succèdent les
figures féminines au tremplin
là encore nous sommes proches de la
perfection
à
avec un tel trio de championne les
allemands peuvent s'envisager les
futures rencontres internationales avec
beaucoup de sérénité
[Applaudissements]
depuis quelques temps des sportifs de la
côte basque s'était fixé pour devoir de
vacances dit acclimater le surfing nez
sur les plages d'hawaii un homme
mystérieux mais un sport sans mystère
muni d'une large planche il s'agit de
gagner la haute mer et de la utilisant
le mouvement des bacs de partir à
l'assaut du rivage
c'est ce qu'ont fait ou essayer de faire
à biarritz les concurrents du premier
championnat de france et d'europe 2 /
fing porté par les fortes vagues des
marées d'équinoxe
maintenant regardez
sans doute penserez vous à présent que
le surfing est un sport passionnant
comme l'ont prouvé pour la première fois
en france les champions de biarritz
[Musique]
un pont sur la manche voilà bien la
nouvelle sensationnelle de ses vacances
encore convient-il de ne pas s'affoler
et de savoirs attend du cap blanc nez on
ne peut encore que sauter dans la mer le
projet ne saurait au mieux être réalisé
qu'en 67
quoi qu'il en soit le pont tel qu'il est
conçu 33 kg net admettra train et
voiture
six mille à l'heure précise t-on à 70
mètres au dessus des flots il sera de
plain-pied si l'on peut dire avec la
falaise du cap blanc nez où sera édifié
une vaste auto gamme et bâtiments avec
magasins restaurants postes d'essence de
tout radar
de moderne d'installation de douane et
de ph
et c'est peut-être ainsi qu'à 100 gap le
non moins fameux projet de tunnel sous
la manche en restera au point où il en
est toujours un trou noir et bien sûr
les signes ne sont pas tous aussi avancé
ceci en angleterre ont résolu au mieux
le problème de l'heure des repas
comme dans la tension la mieux organisée
il suffit de sonner pour être servi
monsieur signe s'est fort bien les
usages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là c'est autre chose
chez ces canards d'une ferme du lac
baïkal on ne commande pas son déjeuner
mais on obéit à la cloche du réfectoire
[Applaudissements]
et deux fois par jour à la peine
règlementaire 21000 canard oui pas moins
se précipiteront de la plage vers les
mangeoires intelligence de l'estomac
aucun champ de clash ne saurait encore
amener les capelains sur les plages de
terre-neuve
à quoi bon d'ailleurs puisqu'ils
viennent de même si abandonnés chaque
été par bancs entiers
c'est l'époque traditionnelle de la
pêche miraculeuse obligatoire et les
pêcheurs s'en donnent à coeur joie
on a eu pas croire c'est charmant
poisson atteint d'un mal étrange rien là
que de très naturel puisqu'il s'agit
simplement de la migration annuelle qui
amènent des capelans déposer leurs oeufs
dans les sables
nouveaux caps l'un du reste ils iront
finir par tono entier comme appât pour
la pêche à la morue et dire qu'ils y
mettent tant de bonne volonté
les vacances sont le temps béni des
rencontres combien de personnages il
habituel rencontré par hasard
voici quelques-uns à turckheim en alsace
le veilleur de nuit des livres d'imagés
toujours vivant chaque nuit depuis 15
140 date à laquelle les registres de
turckheim commence à en faire mention
le veilleur de nuit classique avec
l'interné hallebardes fait quatre fois
le tour du village
[Applaudissements]
est ce le dernier représentant de cette
noble corporation
on peut le croire à saint germain jude
sur les dernières pentes du jura le
garde champêtre fait ses tournées à
cheval il va toi que chacun de ses
administrés connaît aussi bien la
monture que le fonctionnaire et même les
attentions particulières vont plutôt
brave animal
voici quinze ans que monsieur bien qui
exerce ses fonctions voici quinze ans qu
il les exerce à cheval il est sans doute
en france le sol dans son cas maintenant
si l'on cherche les raisons de cette
anomalie pittoresque on ne trouve pas de
réponse ou une seule mais convaincante
ancien gendarme à cheval le garde
champêtre a voulu rester cavaliers
[Musique]
a jouy le châtel le pharmacien est une
pharmacienne rien jusque là que de très
banal mais cette pharmacienne aime la
musique banal encore et son instrument
et le tambour
c'est exceptionnel
thibault
une pharmacienne chef depuis on avait
quand même jamais vu ça
ds d'autrefois et d'aujourd'hui celle de
la saison prochaine verront la hauteur
des jupes diminuer la taille remonter la
ceinture réapparaît voici en tailleur ou
la sq pour un manteau l'insee base et
les petites soeurs de celles qui furent
la vénus d'arles et la diane de gabès
car nous sommes à la fois chez praxitèle
et chez christian dior réunie ce soir au
musée du loup pour cet hiver
les manteaux buste menu s'évase
résolument ancône non étroites et col
miniature garniture de fourrures sont
les traits dominants de cette ligne à la
fois très simple et sophistiquée
[Musique]
pour le cocktail c'était l'heure du
nectar et de l'emploi zee dans le monde
des dieux grecs la ligne sinueuse ou
1000 pis essai transformé mais garde
tout le charme de sa féminité
[Musique]
et
voici les robes et les tailleurs 6
heures minuit décolleté au ras du cou et
la jupe sert les hanches pour s'évaser
au genou
pour les grands soirs et les galas de
l'olympe deux lignes le fourreau
légèrement évasé à bust long et la robe
large et ondoyant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais la fantaisie et l'audace gardent
leurs droits sous l'oeil de zeus les
sont coulés lemond dans leur magie qui
unit sans brutalité le plus beau passer
au charme du présent et qui rapproche si
facilement les femmes de tous les temps
la mode c'est l'heure des ds
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]